[Music]
foreign
good evening you're watching the Press
preview it's a first look at what is on
the front pages as they arrive well it's
time to see what is making the headlines
that's with the daily mirrors associate
editor Kevin McGuire and the telegraph's
deputy comment editor Annabelle Denham
top of the evening to both of you
they're going to be with us from now
until just before midnight so let's take
a look at what is on some of those front
pages well the Metro leads with the Duke
and Duchess of sussex's claim that
Paparazzi in New York pursued them in a
two-hour car chase where collisions were
only narrowly avoided
and the eye pictures Harry and Megan
leaving an event moments before it's
understood that that Pursuit began
the telegraph leads with what it
describes as the massive cost that
obesity is having on the National Health
Service
and the times reports on a 10 billion
pound plan by water and sewage companies
to prevent sewage spills which have been
of course so much in the news for pretty
much all of this year here's the
guardian this is their headline PM
accused of being out of touch over cost
of living
but the express reports that Mr sunak is
planning tax cuts before the next
general election
and the mail suggests that despite
previously insisting he wouldn't secure
starma will in fact try to renegotiate
brexit if he gets to number 10. and the
financial times says that German car
makers are calling on the European
commission to postpone the
implementation of post-brexit import
regulations that they feel would also be
bad for business
and the mirror speaks to a woman who 25
years on from the death of her mother
during treatment at a hospital in
Hampshire is asking police to
investigate why so many patients who
were prescribed opioids at the facility
later died
and the star tells us wait for it this
is a headline and a half that instead of
dunking biscuits in our tea one in 10 of
us is actually doing it with sausage
rolls instead that is just pretty
revolting isn't it a reminder that by
scanning the QR code that you'll see on
screen during the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us
well as I was saying tonight we are have
the pleasure of Kevin McGuire and
Annabelle Denham who are here to talk us
through all of tomorrow's papers have a
good evening to both of you good to see
you as ever on Sky News
um no surprises is it really what's
making the front of quite a lot of the
papers and that is the circumstances
which still don't seem to be clear
um as to what happened to Harry and
Megan in New York um Annabelle what do
you make of all of this story
well I think you know the initial
response of course is going to be one uh
of shock uh for those viewers who
haven't heard about this story this is
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex saying
that they were involved in a near
catastrophic car chase they had just
left an award ceremony in New York uh
this was the Duchess of sussex's first
appearance since
um well since the coronation which of
course she did not attend and they've
said that they with Doria Ragland The
Duchess of sussex's mother was subjected
to a two-hour Relentless Pursuit by a
gang of at least six Paparazzi now the
New York police certainly seem to be
taking this seriously however some
authorities
um have played down the severity and
duration of this incident
um I don't think that means we should
demise it dismiss it I think we need to
find out more details and you know of
course this will undoubtedly have shaken
Prince Harry it has Echoes of what
happened a tragedy that happened to his
mother this is something that he has
repeatedly warned of particularly since
meeting The Duchess of Sussex he did not
want history to repeat itself and here
we are looking at front page splashes of
uh you know an incident that could have
been very dangerous indeed involving
paparazzi
then what's your take on this I mean
given the various uh legal challenges at
the moment raised by the sussexes with
the Press particularly the press in the
UK how are the how are the papers here
treating this story
was noticeable that the two papers that
lead on it the metro and the I uh not
involved in any legal action as far as
I'm aware with uh with a with a with a
couple both but car chase and inverted
commas which is usually attribution uh
rather than actually adopting itself
because clearly something has happened
and it would have been unpleasant for
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex if they
are pursued by Paparazzi flashing away
trying to get their pictures here they
are they are celebs they're going to get
that attention but quite what it what it
is we we've yet to see now they the
couple say it was near catastrophic and
as Annabelle says because he lost his
mother in 1997 in a car crash when that
car do 65 miles an hour the driver was
uh was intoxicated uh it hit a tunnel
wall in Paris she was killed wasn't
wearing seat belt for people in it falls
three who weren't wearing seat belts
died the one who did uh he he survived
of course he's going to be troubled by
being followed and he's spoken in the
past how he sees a flash of a camera or
here's the click of the shutter and it
takes him back to then so he's going to
be traumatized and he's obviously
troubled popped quite what happened is
is I think that I think there to be just
discussed for those who are interested
because it was noticeable yes the the
New York uh police said they
um were assisting them to get home and
it was to challenge you but they say no
reported collisions summons as injuries
or arrests have occurred and inside the
Metro the driver uh sukrum Singh says
yes they were followed but he was never
scared and it wasn't like a Chase in the
movies while if it's near catastrophic
you would think they're going at high
speed round corners uh and it's
terrifying but you know in truth I don't
know yeah
that Recollections may vary to use uh
that well-known phrase and given I mean
a lot will come out won't it I mean
Manhattan is very very uh densely
populated city there's going to be
mobile phone footage would you expect
that this is going to dominate the
papers for the next few days
I think
I think I think I think it's just
already that'll go inside
I don't think it's going to lead the the
front like people have made their minds
up in one way whether they're Forum or
or against them or a lot of us are
somewhere in the in the middle but it'll
be picked over and and maybe Harry and
Megan the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
maybe they have footage themselves from
the black SUV they left in uh he he's
said to have uh taken pictures with his
phone maybe that'll be released
people people I think people would be
interested in and like to see it uh you
know look Paparazzi can can be here very
badly at times unquestionably and it
seems that sussex's wanted to keep
secret where they were staying and who
they were staying with which is their
right but if you do that and you're a
celeb and you're in New York you're
going to get the attention of those
photographers who will want to sell
those pictures around the world yeah
well I expect we'll see some more detail
coming out over the days to come um
Annabelle take us to the guardian
um Rishi sinak being accused of being
out of touch
yes this is a rather a buoyant Rishi
sinach on his way to the G7 Summit in
Japan and on the cover of the Guardian
uh he has been accused of being out of
touch with ordinary families uh he said
that people's household incomes were
hugely outperforming expectations
despite the cost of living crisis now I
mean there may be signs that the economy
is moving in the right direction but to
millions of people up and down the
country it's going to feel like it's
moving in a snail's pace we are still
very much in the midst of a cost of
living crisis and it's strange that
prime minister seems uh to be ignoring
that inflation at 10.1 percent food
price inflation at nearly 20 percent
these are massive uh increases in costs
for ordinary families that are going to
hit them very hard in the pocket um
wages we know from the ons data that
came out yesterday are not keeping up uh
with inflation despite the concerns that
Iran the cover of the Ft from the
governor of the bank of England that we
find ourselves in a wage price spiral
that that certainly doesn't seem to be
born out in the evidence
um that I've seen um and I think that
you know there's a real disconnect there
a seeming disconnect there between what
we're hearing now from the Prime
Minister and perhaps the chance of the
exchequer
um and how families up and down the
country uh and how wealthy those
families are feeling you know who who do
the Tories now think that they are
falling we have had 13 years of
so-called conservative government and
what we have to show for it are high
taxes where of course to have the
highest tax burden in over seven decades
very high levels of government spending
tattered Public Services a seemingly no
appetite for cutting uh cutting that
government spending or reforming uh
areas like the NHS or welfare or
pensions and I think that British voters
are increasingly feeling as though
competence simply isn't enough that was
a rishi's pitch to The Country when he
came in after the chaos of the trust
Administration but it really is past
time now for him to Pivot and set out
what his vision is going to be for the
country